わけですよ 色が無辺だから
それを観察してその状態を体験したんだと
その何にも頼らないで色の無辺状態は作れないんですかと
色 いわゆるその一体感ですか
何にも頼らないで作れないんですかと
さらに訓練を進む 進むんです
うん こういう難しいこと言われますけどね
理解するならば まあ私は疲れませんだけどね
理解するならばどんどん説明できますよ
いっぱい説明あります
理解しなかったら何も意味がないしね
いや あの 一番基本的な説明だけはしてますけどね
まあ一応第二番目の禅定に色の無辺であることを観察して観察して
また一体感があって また一体感があって
何回何回もいったところで定数になるんですね
禅定に それからもう何にも頼らないで
ただ集中するだけで 国境にも頼らない
何にも頼らない ただ集中するだけで無辺状態になるかと
心が すごいんです いわゆる普通の人は何のことなく
いきなりパッと何のことのない体の行動は全部やめちゃって
心も無辺な状態に持ってくる
という状態なんです でもそれは順番でやらなくちゃやらないものなんです
ですから 第四番 第三番目の無理解の心に入るためには
第二番目の状態でいなきゃダメなんです
第二番目の状態でアキンチャニャー
何もない状態を観察している
これは真空状態とは違う
いわゆるナッシングという状態
すごい言葉ではすごいもう違うことは違うんだけど
言いにくいんです 真空といえば物質なんですね
ナッシングといえばナッシングだから
ナッシングネス このナッシングネスということを集中して
それによってまた禅定を作るんです
それはもうアーキンチャニャーヤタナと呼ぶんです
日本語で何て読みますそれは
無少将 ん？無生生ですか
無生はあるという意味でね
ああ まああまりこの日本語のこの漢字だけではね
まあもうわからないかもしれませんだけど
とにかく勉強するということは
この直接こういうふうに理解することであって
このこの翻訳に頼ることじゃないんです
翻訳する人は全部わかっているということも要求することは必要であるし
翻訳っていうのは言葉に言葉を入れ替えることだけですからね
で パーリ語でテキストを読んだってもわからないので
そういうのはやっぱり誰かに教えてもらわなきゃどうしようもない世界なんです
教えてもらったっても
自分でやってみなきゃ
まあ何も意味は持たない世界なんです
とにかくナッシングネス
ナッシングネス 何もないということ
今我々の頭には絶対入らない言葉なんです
ナッシングネスだから認識できないんです
認識っていうのは 心は刺激を受けるっていうことでしょう
心に刺激するためには何かなければ刺激にならないんだから
何も触れなきゃ刺激がないでしょうに
ということは認識が生まれないんですから
ということは 我々は知らないってことなんです
ですから 私たちにとってはナッシングネスの瞑想はできないんです
でも 心は無辺になった人にとっては
何も観察しないで 心に何も刺激を与えないことによって無辺状態に持ってくると
で 合理的に言えばとっても簡単なことなんですよ
心が刺激があるんだから
その刺激によって変化しているだけであって
何も刺激を与えなかったならば
無辺状態にいきなりなるはずなんですね
今我々でも心に何も刺激を与えないようにしましょうと思ったならば
すぐ入るはずなんです
だから問題はどのようにすれば刺激を与えないようにできますかと
体に空気触れるとこれ感じないようにするのも
それは麻酔でもかけてもらっちゃったらいいんだけど
でも脳細胞の働きはどうやって止まってもらいますかね
それも止まっちまう それで人死んじゃうもんだから
だから物質的に世界ではもう不可能な話なんです
でも論理的には心に刺激を与えない
刺激はすべてゼロにする
そうすると心はもう何もつかまるものないんだから
無辺状態に広がってしまっちゃう
そういうことになるんです
でも その状態には順番で丁寧に丁寧に丁寧に心育てていくとなるんです
例えば お医者さんには心臓止まるってことできます
できますけど 機械に入れてでも血液を流れていかないと
瞑想では止まりますよ
無色界では 結構止まるんです
ですから 常識の世界と違うんです
心臓止まっちゃった 人は死ぬだろうと
もう死なない そういう物質的な世界の話ではもう全く関係ない世界なんです
死ぬことはないんだけども
まあそこら辺ははっきりは説明ないんですけどね
まあそれはどうでもいいんだけど
体は植物として働いている可能性もありますけどね
体がまあもし呼吸やらあるならば
その時の瞑想 この瞑想状態の場合は完全に植物です
体が活性したっても 心はすごく違う次元にいるんです
そういう風に この 3番目のアーキンチャニャーヤの禅定に入るんです
ナシングネスということを観察して
何もないということ 何もないということを観察するんだから
この禅定の名前はアーキンチャニャーヤというんです
無生無常だ ですから この無色界では瞑想方法は一つしかないんです
サマーディ瞑想の場合は
方法はいくらでもあるんです
いくらでもあるんです
何かを見て集中すればいいんだから
何かの方法で集中すればいいんだから
いくらでもあるんです
色界超えちゃったら これも心のだけの世界だから
この順番でこの瞑想対象でしか得られないもの
その時のつかむ心理は
全部もう普遍的な心理で
宇宙的な心理で瞑想しているんです
ただ光を見てとかね 何か味覚をとかやったりとかね
念仏唱えるとか そういうちっぽけな対象ではないんです
宇宙の論理でやってる状態なんです
真空状態にたっても それはすごい宇宙的な論理で
心の無辺状態ですね それは宇宙的な論理で
で アキンチニャン ナッシングネスということを普遍的な
そこをナッシングネスということを観察しないと三番目には入らない
そこで四番目に行きます
早く理解するんだから早く早く説明します
無心界の四番目 禅定に出かせれば九番目の禅定
最後の禅定 それは心の究極的な頂点
これ頂点 これ以上の心の育ちがあると言ったら
それはもう意味ない 嘘だけ
ネーワ・サンニャー・ナー・サンニャー
ここでサンニャーという言葉
ネーワっていうのはナー・イワというこのちょっとしたプリフィックスですね
実にありませんという
ような意味なんですね
ナー・イワ・サンニャー
それで次の言葉は ナー・アサンニャー
ネ ナー・イワ・サンニャー
ナー・アサンニャーというふうな言葉をカットしてみればわかるんです
このナー・イワっていうのは
なんとなく会話的に本当に実にないよというふうな
そんなに厳しい言葉ではないんです
このサンニャーという言葉
何でしょうか 色ではありません
それ想と日本語では想と書くんですね
で あの普通の日本語ではなくて
仏教の用語でこの想と書い
想 あのサンニャー で サンニャーっていうのはこの心の働きなんですね
心というよりは で 普通ヴィンヤーナといえば知識
概念 認識というふうな
このなんとなく粗っぽい感じがするんです
想っていうのは このサンニャー
何か感じるだけのことで
何か感じる場合は何か違うところだけ感じる
で 私たちは 例えば二人の
二人の人を見る場合は
二人だよとわかるんですね
で その二人が違うでしょ？お互い
互いに 互いに違うんだから
心の違うところをサッと受け取っちゃうんです
それで二人ですよと 双子を見ていると
双子だから全く同じでしょうに
形が それでも双子だよと取っちゃうんです
なぜならば双子は双子で違うんだから
いわゆる同じ形のは二人がいることも違うことでしょうに
ですから サンニャーっていうのは
この対象の差を受け取っちゃうんです
それで我々の認識が働いているんです
そうでなきゃ何見ても同じく見えちゃうんです
我々は物を見て絶対間違わないでしょうね
たとえ二万円札つ二つ手で取ったら
これ二つだとわかっちゃうんです
それで遊ぶこともできますよ
例えば三人で一万円 一万円紙を出して何かゲームやっていたんだと
ゲームやっていると 真ん中の人いろいろゲームやって終わったところで
じゃあ自分のお金戻そうと思ったら
じゃあこれは私の一万円で
これは私の一万円で これは私の
自分自分前持っていた一万円をまた戻してもらうことはできるんですね
ということは 同じ形の一万円札にしたっても
心がその差を受け取っちゃうんです
差を受け取らなかったら
もう誰のどっちかわからないんです
例えば 新しい印刷したばっかの一万円札三枚持ってきて遊んだならば
じゃああなたはあなたの一万円札
取ってくださいって言ったら取れないかもしれません
一番大切な場合は数字が入ってるんだから
すぐ分ける 苦労すれば分かりますけどね
だからそれでも差でしょ
もし番号も同じやったらもう手上げないんですね
ですから 我々の認識っていうのは
差 物事の差を認識するんです
ディファレンスということを認識するんです
それはよくできてあって
全てのものは無常であって
もう二度と あったものは二度と生まれ変わりませんだから同じものは
だから我々は現金で無常に執着して輪廻転生しているんです
なぜならいくらでも認識する差があるんですね
だから忙しいんです いくら認識したっても
さらに認識するものがあるんです
同じ音楽 同じ歌は何回も聞くでしょ？よくもつまらなく
つまらなげらないで聞いてるんだから
あれは面白いと またなんで二度と面白いと思いますかね？二度目はもう面白くないはずなんですけど
やっぱり二度目聞くとまた違うんです
全てが だから面白がっちゃうんです
そういう風にこの物事の差を認識することは
認識世界の働きなんですね
これはもう厳密に これもう究極的な
この論理的な原理というかね
まあプリンシプルなんですね
認識って何ですかと この壁見て
この壁見てください すぐわかるでしょ
違うと 我々は頭はどれほど悪いと言われたっても
我々の頭はきちんと これは何が
これは何か すぐ見たすぐもう頭に入ってるんです
決して間違わない 間違う場合は工夫するんです
左側のもの 右側のものとか
混乱するのはその あまりにも似ていて間違う時なんですね
その時はお印をつけたりする
まあ例えばまあ小学校一年生の子供たちは
学校に行く時はみんなカバンに
カバンというんですか
リュックサックに名前書いて
全部ラベルを貼ってあげちゃう
なぜならみんな新しい新品ばっかり持っていくでしょうに
だからもう間違うんですね
それで子供たちっていうのは
それほど認識は強くないんだから
もうどうせ自分のごとく置いたところで忘れちゃうんですね
それで名前ちゃんと書いて貼っておく
それで差が生まれてくるんですね
買ったばっかしのリュックサックだから
もう何も スッタクっていうんですか
あれは え？何て言うんですか
買ったばっかしのものだから
もう差がないんです そこでまあ
一ヶ月とか二ヶ月間 あるいは三ヶ月間使うと
もうそれぞれ使い方違いますから
もう差が生まれてきて
名前なくてもわかるようになってくるんですね
ですから 認識というのは
ものの差を確認すること
受け取ること それ鋭ければ鋭いほど
その人は鋭いんです 人間は頭がいいということ
どういうことかというと
サンニャーの鋭さなんです
よく勉強しましたということは
サンニャーの訓練したということなんです
差を受けていることは上手になったということ
音楽を勉強するということは
やっぱり音の差に敏感になることなんですね
音楽は全く勉強していない私にとってはドとレの差が何でしょうか
全然わからないんです
知っていると音を聞いただけで
これはミですよ これはファですよ
これはもうハーフトーンのなんとかですよとすぐ言っちゃうでしょうに
ですから どんな勉強 どんな訓練をしたっても
それはただのサンニャーの訓練なんです
仏教ではこの記憶 仏教心理学ではこの記憶力とかそういう言葉出てこないんです
無意識 記憶力 どのようにものを覚えるかとか
そういう即的な心理学で出てくるみんなありがたがっている言葉全くない
ですからもう心理学の立場で仏教アビダルの勉強しちゃうと
なんか何かちょっと変だなと感じるかもしれませんけど
それは変ではなくて アビダまでその世界をただその一言葉で扱っているんです
人の勉強っていうのは何のことなく
そうの訓練 そうということは
鋭い人は頭がいいんです
例えば一度会った人の顔も名前も覚えているならば
私たちは言うでしょ あの人はすごい覚えがいいんだと
人に一度会ったらもう覚えてるんだと
それはその人のサンニャーが鋭くて
一回見ただけで差はもう刷り込まれる
私でもだいたい回ぐらい人の名前を聞くと
なんとか覚えるんです
あの人は何々さんですよと回ぐらいも聞いてくれないと覚えられませんだけど
回以下だったら 頭の中では回ぐらい繰り返して
あの人は田中さんだ あの人は田中さんだと
言ってなんか名前を忘れちゃうんですね
そこで あれ そうでないと違う工夫でもするんです
例えばクアンゲさん クアンゲさん
クアンゲさんいるんですね
なんで名前を覚えてますかというと
クアン・インという名前があるんですね
それは僕は昔から知ってるんです
ああ クアンゲ あれクアン・インだ
クアン・インと似てるんだと
それで 僕にとってはサンニャーが成長している
サンニャーひとつあったんです
クアン・インというのは観音という音ですけどね
中国の発音で ですからクアン・インって言ってますから
クアン・インということはもう簡単に覚えられるんですけども
ですから 覚えられるのは下手な人はそういう工夫でもして
もう自分慣れてるサンニャーに引っかかってでも覚えようとする
だからものを覚えるということはサンニャーのからくりなんです
私たちのお寺 自分 我々の国っていうのはすごい伝統の国だから
このお寺はいろいろ学問
伝統に入ってるんですね
国ではもう巨大な学問学派ですか
2つありまして 同じ宗派なんですけど
僕らの学派と もう一つの学派っていうのは
ものすごいもうイギリス人とも戦って
仏教を独立するために知識的に戦った人々で
お坊さんたちで どれほど頭良かったというと
イギリスのガバナーさえ自分で寺に来て
何か問題あったらもう半数ぐらいすごい立場が強かったんです
その現代に我々の小さい時いた一番偉いお坊さんが
もうこれを ものすごい頭
もう頭いいというと汗が出るほど頭がいいんです
で 本なんかは一晩で書くんです
本書こうと何か問題があったりして
先生はもう何か言わなきゃ困りますよと言ったら
だいたい何も発言しません
全然 どうしてもしてほしいと言ったら
そうと言って 次の朝もう原稿を持って
はい これ それでもきちんと書いて
何も編集なしに一言葉もそのまま印刷する
それがすごい罰則なんです
ですから この全ての大学を出たことは何もないんだけどね
どんな大学でも学長なんかはもうすごい頭下げて行って
そこに行っていろいろ指導を受けるんです
これはこうじゃないよって言っちゃったら
もう国ごとにそれはそうじゃないと決めて
それで頭がそのお坊さんは僕ら学校にいた時はたまに授業に来るんです
たまになんですけど でお坊さんが授業に現れちゃうと
それはちょっとした大きな出来事みたいなことで
もうその同じランクの学生クラスは全部一つにまとめちゃうんです
だいたい普通のお坊さんが教えてるんだから
もうだいたい人 人分けて教えてるんですね
授業だから そのお坊さんが授業に来るなと思ったら
そういうクラス全部一つにまとめちゃうんです
そうすると結構人ぐらいいるんです
でもみんなの名前入れなくちゃいけないでしょ
一回だけ名前呼ぶんです
リストが空いてます 名前を呼んで
向こうははいと言うんですね
うん マークするんです
それで次の名前を呼んで
次の日そうやって それ一回目
二回目からは言わない
リストを取って 名前見て
そんな感じ 人いたってもう覚えてる
で またどこかやっちゃったらもう名前呼ぶんです
あの暗記力というか もう何者かと思う
本当に人間かと思うほどなんです
そこでこの普通の人々は大学で博士の研究とかよくやってますし
仏教研究の場合はもうお手上げ状態になっちゃったら
もう怖くてそのお坊さんなかなか会わないんですけどね
もう人と会って時間無駄ですからね
で なんとかなんとかコネをして
もう会って話すんですね
もうちょっと分喋ってたら
もう大学の博士論文書くぐらいの情報は全部揃ってる
あなたの研究はこれでしょ？ですから
あのテキストのこれとあのテキストのこれ
あのテキストのページごとに言っちゃうんです
ですから もうすごいといえばすごいんです
ですから その場合はもう僕が言ったのは
まあそれはどういうことかというと
心理学的にああだこうだっていう説明はある
どうでもいいんだけど
このサンニャーの鋭さなんですね
ものすごいサンニャーっていうのは鋭いんです
だから僕らにもよく散々言われたんだけど
あのお坊さん見なさいと
お前らは何ですかとか
やっぱりもうそのぐらいにはもうなりっこないんだから諦めましょう
諦めましょう 僕らも開き直りましょう
開き直って もういいわと
もうもうなりっこはないんです
である日なんですか この現代の若者はパーリ語が下手ですよと
古いパーリ語なんか面白くないんだから
みんな勉強しないんだと
パーリ語の一番難しいのは偈文を書くことなんです
すごく難しいんです そこでその学校のテキストとして
みんなに面白く勉強するような
何かこの偈文を勉強するような何かないかなと問題があって
向こうはもう巨大な学校だから
大学よりはレベルすごい高いんでしたけどね
言ったらじゃあ一つ作りますと
言って一晩で一つのテキストを作ったんです
で 以上偈文があるんです
一晩で書いて それまた全部このまあ文化の中で残る偈文なんですね
偈文と それにすごい綺麗なシンハラ語の歌も同じ節で同じ全く節やら文字の数やら全部ぴったし同じ
どうやって書くか ないんですけど
また学生たちに面白くするために書いたんだだから読んだらすぐ覚えられるんです
苦労して苦労して暗記しようとする必要は全くない
読んでも覚えちゃう 僕もあれを一冊いっぱい一つずつ読んで
結構半分以上覚えちゃったんです
原文は 最初にあった言葉はイティ・ヴィガター・パタマラーティというパーリ語の言葉なんです
それはちょっと一秒 それはこれで一晩は消えた
これで夜が明けたと 最後の原文でこれで夜が明けたと
自分の仕事終わりと 夜しか仕事をしないんです
昼は何もしない 何もしない
夜になったらもう活動するんです
ですから 僕はあだ名をつけていたのは非常に失礼ですけど
夜鳥いるんです なんて言いますか
フクロウ フクロウと名前をつけて
お坊さんも髭生えていつでもそこら辺で見えちゃうんです
体格も素晴らしくて 本当にすごい
見ると本当になんかもうなかなか昼間見えませんだからね
たまに見えるんです 見ればやっぱりなんかみんなそこら辺ずっと見るんですよ
それぐらい やっぱりあれは脳細胞のエネルギーかな
なんかやっぱりすごい人を引き寄せるような
すごいパワーがあるんですね
でも怖くはないんです
いつでもニコニコと いつでも笑ってる声しか聞くもうほとんどもう授業中でも
1時間授業だったら 40分笑ってるんで
一人で自分勝手 それぐらい優しいんだけど
やっぱりみんな怖いと
まあその話はもう全然もうどうでもいい話なんですけど
まあ僕は自分的な個人的な経験にいただけで
そういうあの恐ろしいほどサンニャーが活動する人にとっては
もう何のことでも何のことでも簡単に勉強できる
ですから 勉強するということは
差を頭で認識すること
認識ということは 物事の差を受け取ること
私たちもただ認識しているんだからね
もう全部わかっているんだから
もうメジロ池はメジロ池だと分かっているし
道は道でわかっているし
事務所に行く道はこういうこういうこと
それは全部サンニャーなんです
お互いにみんなお互いに知ってるし
私は名前を覚えてないんだけど
みんなの顔は覚えているし
ですから それはサンニャーなんですね
で このじゃあ無意識下に行きましょう
即席のレベルから ちょっと即席に戻ってもらわないと疲れるんです
で サンニャーという働きは認識にあるんです
いわゆるものの差を取ってるんです
そこでナ・イワ・サンニャー
サンニャーがないようです
実質にサンニャーはしてないようと
ないんではなくて ないよう
サンニャーはなんかありませんみたいな状態
ということは 物事はむちゃむちゃパクパクと認識している状態はいない
認識する状態はありません
そこでナ・アサンニャー
これサンニャーがない
ヒソー これはソー これはヒソー
ソーがない ソーがないところ人が死んじゃったということなんですね
何にも認識しない 何も差はわからない
ということは もう死んでいるということなんです
何も反応ないということは
ですから ヒソーでもありません
でも ソーもありませんし
ヒソー状態でもありませんと
いわゆる心が認識しなくちゃいけないんですね
波を打つためには 最後の最高なレベルで
瞑想の頂点で心がサンニャーもしないし
しないわけでもないと
サンニャーの状態ではなくて
ヒサンニャーな状態でもないんだと
いわゆるその人は本当に心が働いているか
あるいは働いていないかとはどっちでも言えないところまで心が成長させちゃうんです
それ以上心また進んでほしいというならば
死ぬしかないんです 生きてるということはサンニャー取ることだから
今サンニャー取っているかないかという
それぐらいもう機能しない
いわゆる心は波で書くならば
もうほぼ一直線に波がなっているんです
一直線ですけど もうわずかなもう波なんですけど
それ以上波は少なくはならないんです
で そこはこのアキンチャナンという何もない状態体験して
心はまた無辺状態になるでしょう
それからその状態をさらに進んじゃうと
自然的に心は何もサンニャーなくても無辺状態にいるんです
アキンチャナンナッシングネスということもサンニャーなんです
アキンチャナン ナッシングネス
私達には理解できませんだけど
ナシングということは
でもその人にとってはナシングということもサンニャーなんです
これナシンということを認識しない
それでもなくて 心は無辺状態に持ってくる
その状態は非想非想触情と言うんです
そこは瞑想の終わり サマーディの終わり
仏教の瞑想はそこから始まるんです
で この人でこのサンニャーに入ったら
非想非想触情に入っても
お釈迦様が言うのは５つの訓練しなさいと
ずっとその状態でいるわけじゃないんだから
ですから 何回何回繰り返しやって繰り返されてすぐ入る上手になる
それからサマーディから立ち上がる同士になる
時間長い時間いられるようにする
時間に時間をコントロールすることに上手になる
それ終わってから それからこの後観察するに上手になるという 5つの訓練をする
して それにも執着しない
それはもうどんな状態かと
で そこまではお釈迦様は悟り開く前にインドの先生たちから教えてもらったんですから
インドの遠い昔の人々はどれほど立派な人がいたかということでもあるんですね
で そこで じゃあ私たち２人がもう心は育てる究極のところまで行ったんだから
もうそれ以上は育てませんだから
ということは言われたんだけど
お釈迦様はまだ観察しちゃったんだからね
そこでお釈迦様もう一つ発見しちゃったんですね
これ以上は認識はもうできない
認識しない状態だからね
物事 そう受け取れませんだから
ディファレンス 差を受け取れません状態だからね
それでも識 ヴィンヤーナとして心はずっと一直線であろうとも流れているんですね
ほぼ一直線だから その仙人たちがこれは永遠な状態だと思ったんですね
それもまあ合理的に言えばしょうがないんですね
一直線になっちゃったら
もうどこまでも進んでしまっちゃいますから
でももし刺激が入ったらどうするんですかと
いくら一直線といったって
止まるでしょ 止まるじゃなくて曲がるでしょ
荒波が生まれるでしょ
ですから お釈迦様にとってはものすごい明確に
今は心はもう究極の状態に進んだ
でも心が存在しているんだから
また荒波を立てるんだと
いつか 大体八万劫後年かな
もっともっと もうすっごい長い間なんですね
何万 何年か分かりませんだけど
阿僧祇劫という言葉を使ってますけど
その間 茶道のテキストに阿僧祇劫の説明あったんですね
正露は何劫でしたっけ？百？あったね
忘れました それは決まってます
阿僧祇劫という ゼロはまあ四十六劫かな
これはもう無明阿僧祇
心劫と書いてますけど
これは阿僧祇劫っていう
丸 一つの後に丸が百四十
大体はまあこれ状態になっちゃったら
一般的に言えば八万四千劫ですね
八万四千劫が梵天にいるんだと
八万四千劫だから 宇宙の時間単位だからね
これは永遠だと思うのはもう無理のない話なんです
ですから そういう仙人たちがそう思ったのを別にもう批判する必要はないし
無理でもないし それから永遠だと決めたことをお釈迦様は単純な論理で否定するんですね
これは永遠だと決められませんと
なぜならば決められませんからね
ものはね 永遠だとかね
決めるためには自分がより永遠な状態にいて
普通に言えばね 例えば我々は犬が五十年で死ぬよと知ってますけど
ガラパゴス島にいるゾウガメは何歳で死ぬかわからない
なぜかというと 我々は生まれる時も成長して
そのゾウガメはいましたし
我々が死んじゃってもいるし
ダーウィンさんが会った
会ってみたゾウガメは未だにいるんですから
我々は先に死ぬ ですから
人間は知らない 何歳かと
ですから 犬は知ってます
犬のことを 犬よりは僕らの方が寿命は長いんだから
大体寿命同じっても知ってますからね
例えば前の人々はこの動物は何年で生まれたんだと
その先生死んじゃったところで
我々が大きくなったところで死んじゃったら
計算すればわかりますからね
ですから 永遠ということはもう
ですからもう使う言葉ではありません
そんなものは 常識の人は
みんな平気で使ってますけど
知識のある人は使う言葉じゃないんです
それは永遠なりとかね
どうやって言うんですかね
ですから そこで永遠という言葉はちょっと遠慮しましょうということで
お釈迦様が お釈迦様に考えたら
こういう心がこうやって動いているんだから
今まで瞑想体験もありましたから
エネルギーがある限りは禅定にいて
エネルギーが消えちゃうとまた普通の波に戻るんですね
ですから この究極のところまで心成長しても
長い間その徳の力で同じレベルで幸福
至福感を感じているかもしれませんだけど
やがてまた荒波が作るんだと
なぜならば 心の波がここにあるんだから
いわゆるまだまだヴィーラスは完全に消えてないんです
問題作ってたヴィーラスが
心というものは そこでもう一つ
煩悩はもう機能はしてないんだけど
未だに煩悩は活動してるんですね
より高いレベルに行こうではないかと
永遠になろうではないかと
永遠になりたい いわゆる存在欲
ずっと生きていきたいと欲が働いているんです
でもそれは欲として見えません
五欲をもう捨ててるんだから
でもそれも欲なんです
ですから ものすごいレベル高い欲としてそれを扱っているんです
普通の物質的な欲はカーマタンハーというんです
こういう超自然的なところに入りたがるのはバヴァタンハーというんです
有欲 カーマタンハーは普通の五欲と
バヴァタンハーは存在欲ですね
有欲ですね カーマタンハー
これでバヴァタンハーというんですね
存在